hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar a highly
quantitative in vitro method for
mechanistic genotoxicity screening
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrutz and brought to you
by milton yi biotech
to learn more visit miltoniebiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
ermey roy global product manager for
flow cytometry reagents
and dr gail hendricks founder and ceo
of toxis dr roy and dr hendricks you may
now begin your presentations
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today
we will be discussing about
in-vitrogenotoxicity essays
the highlight of today's session will be
presented by dr gil hendrix from toxis
and he will be discussing about an
in-vitroud method
talk striker assay for mechanistic
genotoxicity screening we are very happy
to have
dr hendricks here
to those of you you who are not familiar
with miltoni biotech i have this short
summary here
miltoni biotech was founded in 1989
and over the last 30 years we have grown
significantly
our pioneering technologies have
supported both basic
as well as clinical research which you
can see from more than 20 000 scientific
citations
for today's presentation we have the
following agenda
i will shortly discuss about in vitro
toxicity essays
mainly channel toxicity and how flow
cytometry can support
these types of assays then dr hendrix
will discuss
about the talks checker essay method and
application
toxicity testing in 21st century a
vision and strategy
in 2007 u.s national academy of sciences
have published this landmark report
that envisions increased efficiency of
toxicity testing
and reduces animal experiments by using
qualitative in vitro tests
there are varieties of in vitro test
models
available such as primary cells stem
cells
and 3d system and there are many
benefits for this kind of in vitro
assays
for example they are less expensive they
are very fast and efficient
and this also reduces social pressure
around ethical uses of
laboratory animals you can also perform
a test in a high throughput setup which
of course saves time
and also it can facilitate
multi-parameter
mechanistic insights which will be
focused on today's presentation
assessing general toxicity of compounds
is very important across different
fields
from drug development to chemical
industry
typically carcinogenic potential of
compounds can be characterized
based on identifying dna damage and
monitoring if there are
gene mutations or chromosomal damage
occurred
in order to repair dna damage caused by
this kind of test compounds
there are regulatory authorities like
oecd
or icas provides recommendation for
genotoxicity assessment
which includes test batteries consisting
both in vitro
and in vivo experiments and this again
highlights the importance of in vitro
essays for
such kind of toxicity assessment
talkspecker essay which will be later
introduced by dr hendricks more in
detail is a highly sensitive in vitro
essay
which elucidates mechanism mechanistic
genotoxic properties
and also using plate-based essay format
and it can also be applied in a
regulatory in vitro essay setup
such kind of exploratory essay requires
analysis platform
that offers multiple possibilities
it must be highly sensitive platform
that can be automated
and high throughput but it also must
ensure consistency of the results and
should be flexible so that
one can adapt it in a regulatory essay
environment
if required
max quantx from melting a biotech is a
high throughput flow cytometer
that can offer diverse possibilities
making it
highly suitable for genotoxicity assay
analysis
some of the applications you can see
during the presentation from dr hendrix
this platform is fully automated
and is very simple to use i would like
to briefly um
highlight some of the features that
might be interesting for you
so the automation feature here
includes some basic maintenance to
advanced features
such as sample preparation and data
acquisition and analysis
such automation can significantly reduce
operator
induced variability in results
of course um our platform can support
high throughput
sa analysis it can measure 96 well
played in 15 minutes
and 384 well played in less than one
hour
such automation and throughput comes
without affecting the data quality
which is very important the instrument
offers
industry-leading low sample to sample
carryover
and gives absolute cell counts another
important feature of our instrument is
to ensure data consistency
through multi instrument alignment and i
would just
like to shortly outline this in the next
slide
our flow cytometer devices are truly
universal
when you need to transfer your essays
across departments
and need to ensure performance over time
our instrument ensures such data
consistency through its
multi-instrument alignment feature
basically aligning the
um different instrument settings such as
calibration qc
across different instrument and thereby
ensuring standardization across
different user
instrument as well as location
finally to adapt your assets into more
regulatory environment
you may require analysis platform that
is compatible to better track
your assets through proper documentation
the max quantify software that is
embedded in our flow cytometer
is equipped with fda compliant 21 cfr
part 11
for data acquisition and analysis
these allow you to document user
management
or trail as well as maintain the
electronic records
that can be very important for your
regulatory essays
with this i would like to summarize my
short part
and i hope i could give you a quick
glimpse of
how a high throughput flow cytometry
platform like max quantx
could offer you reliability consistency
and automation
that can be useful for your in vitro
essays
if you have any question about the
technology
you can drop your question in comment
and i can address that after we hear the
section from dr hendrix otherwise
to find further details of our solutions
you can also visit multibiotics official
website
i thank you for your attention and now i
would like to switch the presentation
over to dr hendricks
thank you irmory and welcome to everyone
thank you for the opportunity to uh to
show you what the tox tracker system for
mechanistic toxicity and genotoxicities
can
screening can do especially in
combination with the miltoni max quant
systems
there's a very brief introduction about
the company
toxis so toxic is a dutch biotech
company that is
developing in vitro essays for
toxicological research
but also offers these essays as a
service to uh to industry
and we are we are we are working with uh
with uh
with clients all over the world in the
areas of genetic toxicology
developmental toxicity and mechanistic
toxicity screening
company was founded in 2014 as a
originates from the leiden university
medical center
and i think we are very active in the
various scientific
[Music]
toxic organizations focuses in certain
areas in the toxicological
research primarily in genetic toxicology
and i will show you during this
presentation
uh our talks tracker essay that we
developed in that area
but we also have developed an essay for
a developmental toxicity
reaper tracker and recently
also a new essay called tox profiler
which is focused on understanding
mechanisms of toxicity
but for today i would like to focus on
on our tox tracker system for genetic
toxicology
and that story starts basically with the
regulatory framework for
genotoxicity testing which is well
defined in
in a wide variety of regulatory
documents set forward by the ich and
oecd
and basically the standard approach for
genotoxicity testing relies on on in
vitro
testing followed by in vivo testing uh
both focusing on the on distinct
endpoints that are relevant for for
genotoxicity so for in vitro this is uh
looking for mutations in induction of
chromosome damage
and occasionally also changing
chromosome number or aneuploidy
typically a strategy consists of the
aims test from
for mutations and the micronucleus test
for chromosomal aberrations
if ego testing basically addresses the
same endpoints again mutagenicity
and the classogenicity and endogenicity
using trans-rodent
mutation models big-a
testing and also modern sequencing
technologies are becoming
more and more applied and for chromosome
damage against the micronucleus essay in
blood and bone marrow
obviously this the regulatory testing in
vitro and vivo
can be quite laborious and typically
that's why
more and more we see a screening phase
that is preceding this
these regulatory tests uh that are there
to
to quantify the the potential genotoxic
hazards of
newly synthesized materials combining
technologies
focusing on on on the toxicological
properties of substances combining qsars
or in silicon prediction models
a various screening essays sometimes
screenings versions of the regulatory
essays but also new modern approaches
are being developed and implemented
and one example of this is the tox
tracker system
stocks tracker is a stem cell based
reporter essay
that combines a number of fluorescent
reporters that are stably integrated
into these stem cells
that allow us to detect a number of
genotoxic endpoints the induction
directly of dna damage
but also toxicological effects that
indirectly can cause dna damage
like oxidative stress or protein damage
by combining these different endpoints
in the single assay
toxo is really able to identify not only
whether compounds are genotoxic but also
provide
insight into the mode of action of these
genotoxic compounds
how does this essay work well i said the
essay combines six different
fluorescent reporters each detecting a
specific uh
torxicological effect for the induction
of the
dna damage there's two markers or two
biomarkers in in tox tracker
first biomarker is based on a gene
called bscl2 and this is a gene that is
activated
upon the inhibition of dna replication
following the
formation of bulky dna adducts and as
you will see later
typically activation of this biomarker
really is associated
very well with the formation of
mutagenic dna lesions
the second marker in tox tracker for the
uh for for the detection of dna damage
is a marker called rtkn and this is
activated by the formation of dna double
strand breaks also
clastogenic dna lesions
third markers is a gene called p2 which
is a responsive
gene in the p53 response p53 is a tumor
suppressor gene is activated by dna
damage
but typically also can be activated by
other types of stresses like oxidative
stress
heat shock hyper hypo
hypothermia
so not not only specific for dna damage
then there's two markers for the
induction of the
of oxidative stress reflecting the two
major antioxidant responses in the cell
and finally there's a marker for
activation of the unfolded protein
response
indicating induction of protein damage
and this is then how the essay works
basically it's it's a two-staged
approach where in the first stage
the essay
performs a wide cytosoxicity dose range
testing to identify the concentrations
of a compound that should be applied in
the tox tracker system
so the the stem cells are seated in 96
well plates
we typically prepare serial dilutions in
two-fold dilution steps
and expose the cells another 24 hours
actually using the flow cytometer we can
nicely
measure the the fraction of
living cells in treated versus untreated
samples and that allows us to not only
get a good
cytotoxicity curve determine the
concentrations that should be applied in
the toxic assay
but it also gives an indication whether
compounds are potentially out of
fluorescence
and during the dose finding we also
include a metabolizing system
to see whether compounds require
activation by liver enzymes
then in the second stage the six
different fluorescent reporter cell
lines are seeded again in 96 well plates
the cells are exposed to uh to
five concentrations for every substance
typically again in
in two full dilution steps in the
absence and presence of an s9
metabolizing system
and after 24 hour exposure induction of
those different fluorescent reports
is measured by flow cytometry which of
course makes it very quantitative
because we measure fluorescence on a
single cell level
and at the same time we measure the
fraction of uh surviving cells
so again generating those cytotoxicity
curves and finally
we are comparing the induction of those
different reporters
at the fixed level of cytotoxicity and
compare the induction of the different
reporters to get a
profile for the mechanism of action of
the compound
so here you see an example
uh of uh of of three uh well-known uh
compounds
cis gladin is a dna damaging agent
diazomalliate that induces oxidative
stress and tunicomyosin
as a use of the unfolded protein
response
and you can immediately see the
specificity of the system where
cisplatin primarily activated and read
the dna damage reporters
there's a gray activation of the p53
responsive gene
but there's very little oxidative stress
or protein damage being induced
diethylamiate a really oxidizing
compound in blue activates the two
oxidative stress reporters at a high
concentration there's also some p53
activation
acuticomycin very selectively activates
the protein damage
reporter i have to stress that at these
higher concentrations there are
significant
levels of cytotoxicity being observed
while the specificity of the responses
remain the same as at low cytotoxic
conditions
a set the system is compatible with a
metabolizing system
so we use s9 red s9 for that
we actually optimize the protocol for s9
to
to work optimal for the for the tox
tracker system
and in this example you can immediately
see that the stem cells without the
addition of s9 are unable to metabolize
aflatoxin b1 which is not toxic and not
genotoxic
under these conditions but once the
extra exposure is done in the presence
of s9
immediately the compound becomes
genotoxic activating red again
the both dna damage reporters indicating
that there's formation of bulky dna
adducts there's dna strand breaks being
induced ingredients p53 activation
so clearly the compound is activated by
the s9 and then also becomes xenotoxic
to get a little bit more quantitative
measure on the induction of all those
different reporters across the full dose
range
we generated some software tools that
can nicely work together with the
software from the
max quant flow cytometers
the software imports the the raw flow
cytometry data
and then starts to calculate the the
induction level of every
gfp reporter cell line at different
levels of site toxicity
the software is also able to to export
data
immediately into pros the the
widely available software to do full
dose response modeling
and and calculate dmd values
so this is a typical output from this uh
from the software so it generates these
heat maps where
basically the darker the green the
stronger the induction of the reporter
you can immediately see that
that it helps to classify compounds on
their primary activities
either the inducing dna damage or
oxidative stress or protein damage
and these are calculated efp values in
this example
at 50 cytotoxicity but the software also
allows us to look at lower or higher
levels of cytotoxicity
obviously behind that rather simple heat
map there's there's large tables of
quantification
indicating the levels of of induction of
every reporter at a different level of
cytotoxicity so on the top you see the
different uh
survival levels so cytotoxicity of 10 25
and 50
and every time the software calculates
the amount of induction of that
different reporter
making it possible to look across the
dose range to see what is the level of
induction
that i see for a certain compound
to go on stuff even further as already
said the software is able to
uh to generate output files that can be
uploaded directly into post
which is the the quantitative
dose response modeling software is that
is publicly available
it basically determines the
the full dose response that goes with a
certain data set
it allows people to calculate so-called
benchmark doses so concentration where
they start seeing a certain
uh critical effect and based on the bmd
you can actually rank your
your tested compounds based on their
potency too and use a certain endpoint
has been well validated um
and over the years when when the
performance of the essay is compared
with the standard regulatory essays
for either induction of mutations or
chromosome damage
then the toxic is doing a very good job
in identifying genotoxic compounds with
a high sensitivity and specificity
and obviously people
asked us the question so how does it
then correlate so what is the
correlation between tax checker and
the standard essays that we are also
familiar with
so when we compare the induction of the
top tracker reporter bscl2 that is
triggered by the formation of bulky dna
alex and an inhibition of dna
replication
or we do the comparison one-on-one so
talk tracker versus aims or mla the
correlation is not is around 70 but if
you combine
the standard mutation essays you can
actually see that that the tox tracker
report correlates very well with the
regulatory
uh mutation essays and
or mouse lymphoma essay so around 95
percent
correlation and the same altitude for
um comparison with the second torx
tracker report
rtkn for dna double strand breaks
compared to the micronucleus and or
chromosome aberration essays again
combined we see that 100 of the
compounds that are positive in tox
tracker are also positive in the in
vitro micronucleus assay
but for a significant part of the
compounds that were negative in toxic
there was still a positive result in the
in vitro micronucleus essay
suggesting either that tox tracker is
missing part of the compound
or alternatively of course that the in
vitro micronucleus assay is
oversensitive and detecting some
compounds that are not actually
genotoxic
and we believe that is actually in many
cases
true because if we do the correlation
between tox tracker and in vivo
micronucleus essay
the correlation is very strong and i
think it is generally
acknowledged that the in feature
micronucleus sa has the tendency to
sometimes give a
let's say a positive result that is not
reflecting what is happening in vivo
so the correlation between torque track
and in vivo like a nucleus essay is
actually very good
and currently the essay is being
under evaluation uh both by the european
committee
but but there's an oacd inter-laboratory
validation running
to allow a regulatory application of
this essay
so this is a project that actually
started already a couple of years ago
and involves a number of large
laboratories
in the us and europe and the
experimental work is actually almost
done
and we're now analyzing the data and
hoping to publish the results
later this year
so although talk tracker is very well
able to identify genotoxic compounds
over the last years we have been looking
for for ways to
increase the amount of mechanistic
information that we can get from this
essay
i would like to show you three examples
for this and the first one is
is an extension that we call tox tracker
ace
which stands for energy and glycogen
evaluation
you to be able to discriminate between a
classogenics or a dna reactive substance
and an energetic mode of action where
compounds do not react with the dna
but can cause changes in chromosome
numbers is important also for regulatory
purposes and and
for that reason we extended the talk
tracker assay
with an additional endpoint by looking
at the cell cycle
during exposure and by also measuring
the the the number of chromosomes or the
dna content in these cells and this is
one of the advances of using flow
cytometry
because it's relatively easy to add
those endpoints to the toxic
protocol i would like to share
just a quick example so if we
run four dna reactive substances or
classogenic agent in tox tracker on the
left you can see that all of these
compounds induce the two dna damage
reporters
we would therefore also classify this
compound as genotoxic
now in toxic race we also include
information from the cell cycle so after
four hours and 24 hours we measure the
distribution of the cells
across the different phases of the cell
cycle
in the central part you can see that
after four hours there's very little
impact on cell
cycle distribution not from the blue
cell cycle graph but also on the
quantification that is below that
but after 24 hours you do see that cells
tend to accumulate in
in s phase or g2 phase there's a lot of
cells that have
more than one but less than more than 2n
but less than 4
dna content if we quantify the dna
content in these cells you can clearly
see there's
that there are no cells that have an
apparent chromosome number in this
after exposure
in contrast when we expose the cells to
four well-known energetic agents these
are actually four
tubulin poisons
in tox tracker you can immediately see
that primarily one of the two dna damage
reporters is activated
only when the system is really pushed
into the high toxic
doses then also the second dna damage
reporter is activated but primarily we
see induction of dna strand breaks
but no impact on dna replication
when we now add also information from
the cell cycle already after four hours
we see cells
accumulating in g2 or m phase so
cells really get stuck already after
four hours and this can also be
very nicely quantified after 24 hours
exposure
cells still uh remain stuck in in g2 or
m phase
but now an additional phenomenon is
observed we see a
significant amount of cells that has an
abnormal dna content so an abnormal
chromosome number
and so anuploid is becoming apparent
and this is a mix of aneuploid and
polyploid cells
to follow up on that
so toxic ace can be very nicely used to
identify aneurogenic
agents but of course to dive further
into that mechanism
there's different mechanisms that can
lead to a eugenicity
and so for that reason to further dive
into that mechanism we extend the tox
tracker with an additional cell line
and we call it extension tubulin tracker
so we created a stable cell
that expresses from its physiological
promoter
a g-fact alpha tubulin and the advantage
is that we can look in the context of
the cell to the
dynamics of the microtubule skeleton
the protocol is as follows that we
expose the cells to the compound we
permeabilize the cells and we extract
the non-polymerized so the free
gfp tubulin so we can only
focus on the on the polymerized
microtubules
then we run the cells in the flow
cytometer
and measure the the the the intensity of
the
gfp signals at the same time again we
measure the
the cell cycle distribution
[Music]
obviously because we can look at the
tubulin structures in the in the living
cells you can also look under the
microscope what it actually looks like
and in this slide you can see the added
value of doing that extraction without
extraction
the cells basically are are green
if you extract the non-polymerized
tubulin
you can all immediately see the very
nice tubulin structures in this
filament in the cell
now by using this of course we can use
this setup tool to screen
whether compounds specifically endogenic
compounds
have their have their function to affect
in the microtubule skeleton
and so this this is an example where the
cells were treated either with a tubulin
tubulin stabilizing compound toxol or
with the
tubulin destabilizing compounds in
blessing and you can immediately see the
effects under the microscope
where there's either a loss of any
structure by this indestin
or an accumulation of cells in mitosis
those are the bright spots there
but also you see those filament
structures in the in the cells
of course this can be quantified so we
can
not only quantify the the fraction of
cells in mitosis
by counting mitotic spindles in in
treated cells but we can also measure of
course the fluorescent signals from
those
microscopy pictures and thereby quantify
either where the compounds stabilize or
destabilize the uh
the microtubules but for quantification
the power of course uh lies with the
flow cytometer
where uh on a single cell level you can
quantify the
the gfp signals and again at the same
time measuring the distribution of the
cells over the cell cycle so in this
example these are three
tubulin stabilizing agents and you can
immediately appreciate on the in the
graphs on the right
that indeed with an increase in
concentration
there's an increased signal and so
there's stabilization of the
of the microtubules and at the same time
we see an accumulation of cells in
in mitosis but we treat the cells with
the
tubulin destabilizing agents again cells
accumulate in mitosis but now we see a
strong decrease in tubulin signals
and if we then summarize this in a
little bit broader overview
you can clearly see that we can use this
system to further dive into the mode of
action of tubulin
poisons and identify either tubulin
stabilizing agents
tubulin destabilizing agents or
compounds that do not have an effect
on on the tubulin and is a nice example
there are in this picture three aurora
kinase inhibitors
aurora kinase is important for a
progression of cells through mitosis
um so for these three aurora kinase
inhibitors the cells accumulate in
mitosis very clearly
but still there's no effect on on the
tubulin signals
last example of an extension of the tox
tracker panel i would like to show you
is
a systematic called toxor ao for
antioxidants
and it really helps to uh to
discriminate between
dna direct dna damage and dna damage
that is caused indirectly
by oxidative stress reactive oxygen
species they can
they can react with the dna and then the
first example i would like to show you
is potassium bromate
on the left you can see that the toxic
profile for potassium bromate
induces the oxidative stress reporters
in blue
there's also p53 activation in gray and
if you look carefully the
the dark reds or the marker for dna
strand breaks is also
induced although at a little bit higher
concentration
that already indicates that potentially
the dna damage
is secondary to the to the formation of
of reactive oxygen species
to investigate it further we can run
toxic in the presence of
of rust scavengers compounds that bind
to the reactive oxygen species
typically we use an acetyl-cysteine and
reduce glutathione
in this example in the middle panel you
can see that potassium bromide again
induces oxidative stress
but also activates the rtkn marker for
the formation of dna double strand
breaks
if we expose the cells to potassium
bromate in the presence of the ross
cavity or ncetyl cysteine
or glutathione then we see a strong
reduction of oxidative stress
it's not a 100 but definitely a very
strong reduction but at the same time we
also see a very strong reduction of the
or complete embolism actually of the
induction of dna damage
strongly suggesting that the dna damage
induction that we see
is secondary and is caused by by
by the oxidative stress in the cells
in contrast a second example is is
mms a methylating agent intox
again induces oxidative stress but also
activates in this case both of the dna
damage reporters and also p53 again
it's also here the question again is of
course is the dna damage
induction that we see is that caused by
reaction with the dna
or is it secondary to oxidative stress
where we run the tox tracker again
in the presence of those ros scavengers
in the absence mms causes oxidative
stress
as well as dna damage
are we adding the glutathio anesthetic
cysteine
oxidative stress is strongly reduced but
also the induction of
but but the industrial dna damage is not
affected suggesting that mms directly
binds to the dna
and the dna damage is not caused
secondarily to oxidative stress
which is in line with with with the
literature because mms
is a methylating agent that methylates
dna and is also a mutagen and in
vivo carcinogen um
when we expose the cells in the presence
of glutathione also daily oxidative
stress
is reduced but now we do see a reduction
of of the dna damage response and that
is because
glutathione binds directly to mms so
here we're not scavenging
the reactive oxygen species but we're
actually rather scavenging mms itself
so there's always some causes by
interpreting these
these data then to summarize just some
practical facts about the essay
so for pharmaceuticals typically the top
concentration is one millimolar
chemicals up to 10 millimolar in line
with the
recommendations from the different
regulatory agencies
either we require about five to ten
milligrams for for pharmaceuticals fifty
two hundred milligrams for chemicals if
we need to go up to that high
concentration
standard turnaround time is about two
weeks although there's a
express service where we can deliver a
report in three days
uh typically we can test let's say
between one and twenty five to thirty
compounds per week
and the sa is compatible with the usual
solvents like dmso pbs water ethanol
the essays have been shown to be
compatible with the right
range of materials obviously small
molecules
but also polymers complex mixtures
nanomaterials
and also all kind of intermediates that
are tested for occupational toxicology
a talk tracker is available
as a service from toxis but
a stock tracker but also toxic raise it
is also available through
charles river as a partner and by using
these outsourcing platforms like
scientist.com
the talk tracker is also available as a
kit so labs can buy
toxic kits to run it in their own
facilities
and we we always have the opportunity to
set up the multi-year licenses to really
fully support integration of this essay
in the laboratory
and with that i would like to thank you
thank you dr roy and dr hendricks for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question
is
are you planning to have a talks tracker
lab training course later this year
yes so this is phil hendricks um yes
there are plans
uh different plans actually to have a
tax tracker lab training
there was actually already scheduled for
last year but then obviously due to the
covert situation that got postponed but
there are two activities that we are
that we are working on one is a
uh this is a lab training actually
in our lab facilities in the netherlands
uh and the second uh uh thing that we're
working on actually together with
miltoni
is if possible host a practical workshop
alongside the eurotox conference that
will be held later this year
that will happen in copenhagen
but of course it depends a bit on the
other covert situation how that will
develop
but once possible yes there will
definitely be possibilities for a
hands-on training
either in our facilities or at the
external side
thank you dr hendricks our next question
what is the rationale for using mouth
stem cells versus human
or non-stem cells
yeah there are various answers to that
question
we from the start decided if we want to
capture
the cellular responses related to
genotoxicity we need a cell system
that is basically
[Music]
reflecting normal cells so we didn't
want to use cancer cell lines or
transform cells
so primary cells is the way to go but
obviously they are not very well
maintained in the lab and we can
definitely not modify it and so stem
cells
turned out to be a very good platform
for this
for this subject by the time that we
started the development of tox tracker
the uh the human steps of human
embryonic stem cells were available but
there were obviously all kind of ethical
reasons
uh not to use these cells and human
induced pluripotent stem cells
they were simply not invented in those
days so um
so for that reason we we made use of
mouse embryonic stem cells
uh also because there was a huge number
a huge amount of information available
from these data
toxicogenomics mutation data
genetically very stable nicely deployed
i have a normal cell cycle control in
our dna repair proficient
and in due course we obviously discussed
whether we should switch to human cells
especially after the let's say the the
improvements on the
induced pluripotent stem cells um
but we decided to stick with with the
mouse cells i think these are
very well fit for purpose
the system is able to identify around 95
of all human in vivo genotoxins
so there's really no nothing much to
gain
it's not simply possible to transfer the
reporters to human cells
so we would really have to start from
scratch and of course with the
validation and the ongoing always
evaluation constructor it would be a
large step back but i said fit for
purpose i think in this case
is the reason the only area where mouse
and human might differ
is in metabolic metabolism so
metabolization by liver instance for
instance on both human and mouse stem
cells do not have a lot of
metabolization
activity so we have to rely on on an
external metabolization source anyway
so the simple answers yes we thought
about it but i think
there's a lot of good reason to stick
with the mouse cells
we have no indication that the situation
or the sensitivity will improve
by switching to human cells in this case
okay thank you dr hendricks we have
another question
is the talks tracker suitable for other
flow cytometers
yes that is uh that's a fair question
and the answer is yes
so as far we are
running essay also on the on different
brands of flow cytometers
and as part of the oecd validation the
external labs
are also using different brands ranging
so far i have to say we have not
encountered a flowcharter
that is not compatible with the
wiki system of course there are
differences in speed
and ease of use and the software that is
associated
yeah so there are different differences
but the sa seems to be compatible with
basically the whole system as long as
they have a
96 well or ideally even a 384 well
reading capacity but the speed differs
definitely between those systems
okay great thank you again and another
question
any measures regarding mitochondrial dna
uh no no i don't see it now
uh the uh
um so we have we have not been able in
previous studies
not used to this so is talks tracker
capable of analyzing a mixture sample
such as hemp extract
which may induce more than one type of
stress or stresses
um yes and no so yes definitely
we've tested we and others have tested
uh
a wide range of different mixtures uh
from let's say artificially
reconstructed mixtures with a few
compounds
up to very high complexity mixtures like
like oil extracts which really contain
more than a million different molecules
and i think in most of the cases it was
definitely
possible to to detect um
genotoxic pollutants or genotoxic
factors in those mixtures
um the sensitivity of the sa is is high
so that means that also small fractions
of pollutants or
genotoxic constituents could be
identified
obviously it is not possible to identify
which compound in there is causing a
certain effect
but it's definitely possible to detect
uh for instance the induction both
oxidative stress dna damage
um and then i think using extension
protocols or
or let's say using for instance
[Music]
protocols that also include kinetics of
reporter activation
it is definitely possible to detect
different mechanisms of action
but obviously again it's it's impossible
to then determine which compound or
which fraction in that mixture is
causing the
the effect
okay thank you so much dr hendrix let's
see
i've got time for one more question here
um
has the assay only been validated using
small molecules
and chemicals or were there also other
types of materials tested like
nanoparticles mixtures or natural
extracts
yeah that's a good and a fair question
obviously most of the validation work
has been done with
with with pure small molecules with pure
chemicals
um there there's quite extensive
data from the tox tracker system
and nanomaterials by others but also we
have been involved in the number of
collaborations with different labs in
the world and most of the work is
actually published
the system seems to be very compatible
with nanomaterials
and we've always taken care that we
measure the actual cellular uptake and
look at intercellular localization and
that seems to work very well
we've definitely also did some mixture
studies
some of the data had been published
mostly on posters
for instance the sot to get
both for for mixtures related to
to e-liquids
[Music]
environmental samples and petroleum
products
um we've had a little experience with
testing
other modalities like
like proteins or oligonucleotides but
that
that data is very limited in all honesty
so uh
well thank you so much dr roy and dr
hendricks
for your time today do you have any
final comments for our audience
and friends people yeah yes
if people have any questions related to
the uh to the top tracker system
or our experience together with uh if
you know any systems then
yeah feel free to reach out through the
website or
i guess uh through uh maybe through the
chat
well thank you again dr roy and dr
hendricks for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor milton yi
biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye